parce que notre ville se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
équilibre votre magazine sur
l'environnement ce mois ci dans
l'émission nous abordons le thème de la
mobilité durable le mois dernier
l'organisation mondiale de la santé il a
annoncé la pollution de l'air extérieur
est devenu cancérigènes la faute
notamment aux gaz d'échappement des
moteurs diesel nous devons donc trouver
des solutions au moins polluantes et
changer nos modes de déplacement pour en
parler nous irons prendre des nouvelles
de la twizy ce petit véhicule électrique
en service de tous partagent dans les
rues de saint quentin en yvelines nous
partirons ensuite à buc pour présenter
les bus électriques be green qui se sont
implantés le mois dernier dans le 15e
arrondissement de paris mais tout de
suite nous partons à vélizy villacoublay
dans le centre de maintenance du tramway
6 pour parler des transports du futur
avec la ratp entretien
hannachi zoomer bonjour merci de nous
recevoir ici dans ce tramway 6 la ratp
met en place actuellement un projet le
projet sismo 2015 alors pourquoi la ratp
met en place un tel projet est bien la
ratp a participé à la mise en place de
ce projet et on assure maintenant la
coordination pourquoi parce que en tant
que transporteur elle pense que l'on ne
peut plus se limiter à penser en termes
de transports en commun mais qu'il
s'agit maintenant d'imaginer la mobilité
de manière globale
à partir des infrastructures de
transport existantes il s'agit
d'imaginer les nouveaux services qui
vont compléter ses services de transport
en commun et puis aussi les
organisations qui vont permettre de
rendre ces services sécurisés fiables et
économiquement viable et puis également
attrayants et ce sera certainement une
condition de leur succès pour les
usagers alors quels sont les objectifs
de ce projet sismo 2015
le projet sismo 2015 part d'un constat
sur le territoire de paris saclay qui
est un territoire qui est constitué de
quelques grandes agglomérations comme
versailles saint quentin massy mais
également des espaces très peu denses en
son centre avec des activités
industrielles à l'ouest mais aussi un
gros pôle de recherche et d'enseignement
sur l'est donc un gros un fort une forte
demande de mobilité et ce territoire va
aller en ce développement avec notamment
le projet de grand paris mais par contre
on constate avec le les problèmes
d'infrastructures existantes les grandes
les grandes infrastructures de voirie
mais aussi de transport en commun qui
n'irrite pas dans la danse la finesse du
territoire on constate un manque
d'accessibilité de ce territoire à la
saison mais concrètement comment ça va
s'articuler pour l'usager alors le
projet ne définit pas a priori
l'ensemble des services l'ensemble des
spécifications de ses services puisque
on va commencer par une phase de
rencontre avec les usagers pour lever
les questions de frein déterminer les
conditions d'acceptabilité des services
et avec cela nous allons pouvoir définir
ce que cela va être par contre je peux
déjà vous dire qu'il s'agit dans le
volet information voyageurs de
développer un système d'information donc
une application qui pourra donc être
mobile est consultable à tout moment par
les usagers et qui pourra que le
l'usager pourra interroger pour savoir
au moment où il part il peut aussi
programmé bien évidemment mais il peut
le faire en temps réel ses 10 rebonds
main par exemple moi je suis un usager
je viens de descendre de monde - rer
j'arrive de paris je suis à saint
quentin je viens de rater le bus qui
devait m'emmener à mon entreprise a
peut-être 20 minutes de route d'ici
effectivement je peux y aller à pied
mais je vais être en retard mais il se
trouve qu'un vous être un conducteur
vient de poster une annonce de
covoiturage on se donne rendez vous sur
le parking à haut niveau de service là
où une station covoiturage a été
aménagée de façon très reconnaissable
pour pouvoir se retrouver partir dans ma
direction on peut aussi imaginer dans le
sens inverse quelqu'un qui habite dans
les environs qui prend sa voiture tous
les matins elle et elle n'est d'aucune
utilité dans la journée eh bien il se
dit pourquoi ne pas la mettre en
location entre particuliers le système
si ce mot va pouvoir lui permettre non
seulement de réaliser cette cette mise
en ligne de
sa voiture mais avec le la non seulement
en ligne mais eux mêmes en réseau
puisque le système si ce mot va pouvoir
lui apporter d'autant autant
d'utilisateurs du système et donc de
deux locataires potentiels qu'il n'ya
par exemple d'usagé qui prennent les
transports en commun et qui arrive sur
la gare là où il a garé sa voiture donc
il pourrait la gare et le matin
rencontrer quelqu'un qui vient de paris
il pourrait se donner les clés et
ensuite lui partirait dans l'ain pour
son trajet et sa journée de travail sur
paris l'usager qui vient de paris lui
aurait à sa disposition une voiture pour
la journée ce qui lui donnerait aussi
une large possibilité de déplacement en
cours de journée s'il doit se déplacer
sur le territoire c'est grâce aussi à ce
service que les habitudes vont changer
chez les usagers exactement le
changement des habitudes et des
comportements dont on parle en fait il
ne s'agirait là que donc une conséquence
de notre projet et c'est ce que bien ce
que l'on vise grâce à 7 assez mis ses
services que les utilisateurs vont
pouvoir tester pendant la durée du
projet nous espérons les convaincre
aussi deux voilà de changer leurs
habitudes de les re questionner
puisqu'on le sait que quand quelqu'un à
a pris l'habitude des transports en
commun et plus souvent on a pris
l'habitude de la voiture il est très
difficile de le remettre en situation de
vouloir changer ses habitudes là le
projet sera l'occasion pour lui de
tester de nouvelles mobilités de se
rendre compte que participer au système
lui permet aussi en retour des bénéfices
collectifs qui sont supérieurs à ce
qu'ils pouvaient faire individuellement
et un site c'est ainsi finalement
construit co-construire la mobilité
globale sur le territoire ce projet
sismo quand est-ce que nous pourrons
profiter nous usagers alors il s'agit
d'un projet qui a été financée qui est
financé par l'ademe dans le cadre des
investissements d'avenir suite à l'appel
à projet de
mobilité des personnes mobilité durable
des personnes il va se dérouler sur
trois ans nous sommes encore en phase de
fin de contractualisation mais si tout
se passe bien nous avons nous pourrons
imaginer les premières expérimentations
fin 2014 ou début 2015
merci beaucoup à nous tous mais de nous
avoir reçus ici dans ce maelström de 6 à
des taux
il y a un an la renault twizy arrivée à
saint quentin en yvelines aujourd'hui sa
gestion a été reprise par kim ouvre une
société chinoise alors qu'est devenu ce
petit véhicule électrique à mi chemin
entre un scooter et une voiture réponse
dans ce sujet
mise en place par renault en septembre
2012 sur saint quentin en yvelines la
twizy vient de fêter son premier
anniversaire dans la communauté
d'agglomération petite auto électrique
qui fonctionne via un service
d'autopartage elle n'est cependant
aujourd'hui plus géré par le
constructeur français sait désormais qui
move une pme de 40 salariés qui a repris
le flambeau une société qui souhaite
faire de la twizy l'exemple type du
moyen de transport urbain de demain pour
cela le véhicule se transforme pneus du
véhicule adapté selon les saisons
porte-bagages installé à l'arrière et
des vitres pour l'hiver voilà pour le
confort
côté stratégie la pme souhaite
développer l'utilisation de sa twizy par
les entreprises et la démocratiser dans
les habitations il est absolument
indispensable que les bâtiments de
demain intègre des moyens de mobilité
durable
partagé par les différents occupants des
immeubles au même titre que aujourd'hui
on fournit un ascenseur dans une
copropriété ou via un court de tennis ou
une piscine donc il faut vraiment
considérer que le moyen de développement
le moyen de mobilité électrique soit
associée ainsi qu'à la consommation
une nouvelle offre d'abonnement twizy
pour les usagers verra le jour printemps
2014 che qui move en avance le prix d'un
abonnement mensuel aux alentours de 6
euros pour 12 euros de l'heure
d'utilisation du véhicule avec près de
10 % de croissance par mois et environ
1000 abonnés aujourd'hui la twizy
continue en tout cas de tracer sa route
le mois dernier les bus se 100%
électrique begreen s'implanter dans le
15e arrondissement parisien cet autocar
dominique une entreprise basée à buc qui
a réussi l'exploit historique de casser
le monopole de la ratp reportage
15e et à une colline
on va toujours monter quand on va vers
la porte de versailles quelle que soit
la solution empreinte est donc celle là
il bien c'est un peu spécialisés pour
les gens vraiment avec le mobilité
réduite avec
c'est parfois on est des trajectoires
entre 2
pour marie et valentin le courant semble
passé avec les minibus électriques be
green en circulation depuis un mois dans
le 15e arrondissement de paris ces
petits véhicules coloré silencieux ont
réussi un gros coup détrôné pour la
première fois depuis 1949 la ratp sur le
pavé parisien propriété de l'entreprise
autocar dominique basée à buc les bus be
green sont le fruit d'un investissement
risqué patrick mennucci pdg de la
société prend le pari d'en acheter 3 au
constructeur italien the bread à en
novembre 2009 il les propose dans la
foulée à ses clients le ministère de la
santé microsoft safran france
télévisions est maintenant la mairie du
xvème tous ceux se montre séduit et à
deir projet de green tous ses clients
ont été conquis nous avons pu leur
proposer une alternative électrique à ce
qu'ils avaient jusque là jusqu alors à
savoir du transport thermique équivalent
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes en
transport propre avec du zéro d'émission
de co2 et politiques comment ça met des
feuilles de route qui me paraissent un
peu durable donc ça c'est une des
grosses clés parce que les industriels
ont besoin d'un feu vert
dans la durée pour pour construire des
véhicules ils savent le faire et je
pense que c'est bien parti tout ce qui
concerne le ramassage de personnel de
proximité le transport dans les
collectivités locales en hypercentre
notamment peut être parfaitement
exécutée avec ce type de matériel donc
effectivement c'est une partie de
l'avenir du transport collectif donc
avec ce transport propre déjà installés
en région à l'île de ré dans les
pyrénées et les alpes l'entreprise
yvelinoise va continuer son
développement notamment en ile de france
et dans de nouveaux arrondissements
parisiens avec un parc d'une vingtaine
de bus 100 % électrique be green se
positionne en tout cas déjà comme le
leader européen en la matière
c'est la fin de ce numéro d' équilibre
consacré à la mobilité durable mais
avant de se quitter place à la jada
découvrez au la lola un spectacle
aquatique le mercredi 4 décembre à 15
heures à la maison de l'environnement
tambour doux clapotis rythme et ça l'a
dit appuie et de drôles d'instruments
connu mais vous musical accompagné 20
bénévoles de la lpo partez à la
découverte des oiseaux au parc des
sources de la bièvre le dimanche 6
décembre découvert un espace aux milieux
variés à deux envolées du centre de
saint quentin en yvelines enfin le
mercredi 18 décembre l'atelier de l'eau
pour vivre va permettre aux enfants de
comprendre les problématiques de l'accès
à l'eau dans le monde sous forme de jeu
ce numéro d' équilibre se termine merci
à tous de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez
vous le 20 décembre et d'ici là
n'oubliez pas la terre est notre mère
respectons la salut